let's see if we can prove to ourselves
some more reasonably interesting
transpose properties so let's define
some matrix c that's equal to the sum of
two other matrices a
and b
and so any entry in c i can denote with
a lowercase c i j so if i want the i
throw and j column would be c i j and so
each of its entries are going to be the
sum of the corresponding columns in our
matrices a and b
so our i i j entry in c is going to be
equal to the i j entry in a plus
the i j entry in b that's our definition
of matrix addition you just get the
corresponding entry in the same row and
column add them up and you get your your
entry in the same row and column in your
new matrix it's the sum of the other two
now let's think a little bit about the
transposes of these guys right here so
if a
if a looks like this
i won't draw all of the entries it takes
forever but each of its entries are i
j just like that
let's say that a transpose looks like
this each of its entries
we would call it let's say if you've got
that same entry we're going to call it a
prime a prime i j and these things
aren't probably going to be the same
there's some chance they are but they're
probably not going to be the same
but that's it's ijth entry in the i
throw jth column in a transpose now the
fact that this is the transpose of that
means that everything that's in some row
and column here is going to be in that
column and row over here that the rows
and columns get switched so we know that
we could write that a prime a prime i j
a prime i j we're going to have the same
entry that was an in that was in a
ji
aji maybe aji is over here aji is over
here so this thing over here which is in
the same position as this one is going
to be equal to this guy over here if you
switched the rows and columns i think
you can accept that and you can make the
same argument for b
let me actually draw it out so if i make
b transpose b transpose
the entry in the i throw in jth column
i'll call it b prime
i j just like that just like i did for
a
so we could say that b prime
i j is equal to
you take the matrix b but it's going to
be the entry that's in the j throw and
ith column these are you could almost
say the definition of the transpose if
i'm in the third row and second column
now it's going to be what was in the
second row and third column
fair enough so what is
so we already have what c i j is equal
to what's the transpose of c i j going
to be equal to
let me write that down
so c transpose
let me write it over here
all right c
transpose is equal to i'll use the same
notation the prime means that we're
taking entries in the transpose
so c transpose is just going to be a
bunch of entries i j
i'll put l prime there showing that
that's entries in the matrix of the
transpose and not in c itself and we
know that
c
prime
i j
is equal to c
j i nothing new at all we've just
expressed kind of the definition of the
transpose for these three matrices
now what is c
j i equal to
so let's focus on this a little bit what
is c j i equal to we know that c i j is
equal to a sub i j plus b sub i j so if
you swap them around this is going to be
equal to you just swap the j's and the
i's a sub j i
plus b sub j i i just used this
information here you could almost view
it as this assumption or this definition
to go from this to this if i had an x
and a y here i'd have an x and y here
and an x and a y here i have a j and i
here so i have a jane and i there and a
j and an i right there
now what are these
what are these equal to
this is equal to
this is equal to
this guy right here
is equal to we do it in the green
is equal to the same entry
for
the transpose of a at i j
at i j and this is equal to the same
entry for the transpose of b at i j
the transpose of at b at i j
now what is this telling us what is this
telling us it's telling us that the
transpose of c
which is the same thing as a plus b so
it's saying that a plus b
a plus b transpose a plus b transpose is
the same thing as c transpose let me
write that c transpose is the same thing
as a plus b transpose so these are the
entries in a plus b transpose right here
and what is this over here what are
these
these are the entries right there we do
the equal sign over here
what are these these are the entries in
a transpose
plus b transpose
right this is these are the entries in a
transpose as the entries in b transpose
if you take the sum of the two you're
just adding up the corresponding entries
so that's straightforward to show that
if you take the sum of two matrices and
then transpose it it's equivalent to
transposing them first and then taking
their sum
which is a reasonably
reasonably neat outcome let's do one
more and i think we'll finish up all of
our major transpose properties
let's say that a inverse
this is going to be a slightly different
take on things we're still going to take
the transpose so if we know that a
inverse is the inverse
of a
that means
that means
that a times
a inverse is equal to the identity
matrix assuming that these are n by n
matrices so it's the n-dimensional
identity matrix and
that a inverse times a is also going to
be equal to the identity matrix
now let's take the transpose of both
sides of this equation let me start with
i'll do them both simultaneously so if
you take the transpose of both sides of
the equation you get a times
a inverse
transpose is equal to the identity
matrix transpose now what's the
transpose of the identity matrix let's
draw it out
the identity matrix looks like this you
have just ones
all the way down diagonal and everything
else is zero
everything else is zero
right and this is you can view this as i
one one i two two all the way down to i
and n everything else is zero
so when you take the transpose you're
just swapping up the zeros
right these guys don't change the
diagonal does not change when you take
the transpose so the transpose of the
identity matrix is equal to the identity
matrix is equal to the identity matrix
and so we can apply that same thing here
let's take the transpose for this for
this statement so we know that a inverse
times a
transpose is equal to the identity
matrix transpose which is equal to the
identity matrix
and then we know what happens when you
take the transpose of a product it's
equal to the product of the transposes
in reverse order
so this thing right here we can rewrite
as a inverse
transpose
times a transpose which is going to be
equal to the identity matrix we do the
same thing over here this thing is going
to be equal to a transpose
times
a inverse transpose which is also going
to be equal to the identity matrix
now
this is an interesting statement the
fact that if i have this guy right here
this guy right here times the transpose
of a is equal to the identity matrix and
the transpose of a times that same guy
is equal to identity matrix implies
this implies
that
a inverse
transpose
is
the
inverse
of
a transpose or another way of writing
that is if i take a transpose
and if i take its inverse that is going
to be equal to this guy
it's going to be equal to a inverse
transpose so another neat outcome
dealing with transposes if you take the
inverse of the transpose it's the same
thing as the transpose of the inverse